coronavirus case numbers are dropping
that's good news but the experts worry
that the upcoming spring break travel
will create new super spreader events
just like the one last year that was not
good news florida is one of the top
destinations for spring breakers we know
that
manuel bajorka shows us how officials in
south florida
are struggling to prepare for
potentially very large crowds
[Music]
the sun and sand of south beach is
synonymous with spring break
but for thrill seekers who get out of
control miami beach mayor dan gelber has
a warning
if you're coming here to go crazy go
somewhere else you're going to be
arrested
he's hoping to avoid scenes like these
from last year's
spring break i get corona i get corona
at the end of the day i'm not going to
let it stop me from partying
that helped seed south florida with
covid last spring
the city has stepped up its police
presence banned open alcohol containers
and set capacity limits on its most
popular beaches
but statewide rules prevent gelber from
enforcing a mass mandate
or capacity limits on most businesses do
you really think that your restrictions
for spring break will make a difference
or is it trying to hold back a tidal
wave with a cup listen i don't know but
you got to do what you can do we're not
going to eliminate risk we're simply
going to try to manage it with
the tools we have one of those tools is
a midnight curfew which means south
beach
isn't exactly what tourists like lauren
gibbons expected we wanted to go out to
bars and you know have a good time
because
it's south beach it's miami nobody wants
to be done at 12 midnight so
it was a bummer but i'm still having a
blast that's what businesses here
are hoping for customers comfortable
with the new normal
our goal is keep you safe and give you a
good time
so you're not letting things be the wild
wild west out here
far from it mohan coca is the general
manager of the kimpton surf comer hotel
he says hotels and restaurants depend on
this season for profit
but after the virus devastated the
industry last year
they are not looking for another
lockdown i believe that from what we
have done
people can be safe but there is always
an individual responsibility this is a
two-way street
it's a tricky balance to strike
according to stephen seiwitz
he's the chief operating officer at
joe's stone crab
a miami institution we're in the people
pleasing business we're in the yes
business now we're in the proctoring
kind of business but the truth is
is we're in a pandemic thank you joe's
has been in se with his family for over
100 years
he says when the shutdown happened last
year he wasn't sure
they'd make it but he says protecting
the public is just good business
i thought this was possible i said who's
going to walk into an empty restaurant
i thought they wanted the crowd and
never thought that it would
take like it has and it's been very
positive
i mean this is a matter of life and
death so we just have to take the proper
precautions
hotel bookings are already estimated to
be 20 percent higher this march than
they were
last year before the virus took off the
mayor says he's definitely concerned
about the potential
for a super spreader event and not just
concerned about what tourists could be
taking home
but what they could be bringing in and
leaving here tony
that's a good point manny thank you very
much